we do this together okay
[Music]
ever since your coronation you had to
learn how to control your powers Elsa
you could have been learning your whole
life but your parents made you conceal
your powers from your people apparently
the wise trolls in the forest always for
your posters powers were too much for
this world but now that something is
threatening arendelle they're scared
your powers might not be enough to save
them all we know you'll try your hardest
to save your people Elsa in the first
movie else's power seems too powerful to
get a grip on but frozen to has us
asking if Elsa's powers will be enough
keep watching to find out hey Spanish
speakers we've got an exciting new
announcement from the folks over on
screen rads devil iguana an old Spanish
channel for field theories MCU coverage
movie news and much much more
we have videos for fans of well
everything so jump on over to DPS
channel and let them know we send you in
Spanish of course don't forget to
subscribe and hit the notification
barrels the threat to arendelle in the
first movie the threat to arendelle was
caused by Elsa she didn't have control
of her powers and launched the kingdom
into a massive Blizzard but in frozen -
the threat appears to be coming from
somewhere else
elsa has learned how to control her
powers but some force sweeps through
arendelle everyone runs for the hills
literally from the trailers it appears
to be some other natural force but
instead of ice like Elsa's magic it's
wind this wind is strong enough to blow
Sven out of a barn when storms can be a
natural disaster all on their own
causing massive destruction but
disappears to be magical wind elsa and
anna lead their people to the cliffs and
the trolls show up they tell Elsa that
she must find the source of her power
this is related to her stopping whatever
it is causing the threat the troll
leader also tells Anna that he fears
Elsa's powers won't be enough yikes
that is one scary magical wind Elsa's
powers we know that Elsa can manipulate
ice and snow she can even conjure them
out of nowhere but it appears that her
powers are even stronger than that
we see her attempting to turn the entire
sea into ice and she appears to be doing
a pretty good job but unfortunately for
her salt water doesn't like to freeze
she is apparently able to conjure a
horse made out of ice to save herself
without even knowing it these powers are
going to help Elsa make it into the
enchanted forest but there's another
important clue about Elsa's powers
Disney released a small clip of the new
song into the unknown in it Elsa says
that her powers are growing stronger
every day
Wow Elsa is already incredibly powerful
but will she become strong enough to
arendelle the enchanted forest Elsa and
Anna have a flashback to their father
telling them about an enchanted forest
it was a magical place but something
where some sort of dark power now keeps
anyone from going in or out and it
appears that some people are trapped in
there too
what we have seen from the enchanted
forest shows a lot of magical winds and
pink fire the trolls warned Elsa spirits
which are usual at first we think that
whatever this dark magic or dark spirit
is in the forest is the same thing
threatening arendelle this is why Elsa
must go north
but the enchanted forest also holds the
answers to else's questions about her
powers she must go into the unknown she
also hears a voice calling to her from
the north is this voice an actual person
it could be someone who wants to help
her to discover the truth or it could be
the people who are trapped there calling
out for help they could also be whatever
darkness is spreading from the forest
into arendelle
the answer there's a good chance that
the answer lies in a tiny adorable clue
the latest trailer show Elsa with a
little bloom lizard-like creature she
sprinkled snow over him he's super cute
we also see her talking to him
she's asking him for answers and he
doesn't appear to be answering but we
see him launch himself over a big rock
like he wants Elsa to follow this little
lizard is going to lead Elsa to the
answers about her powers
we then see her descending into an ice
cave the forest has Wind and Fire but
now it has ice Elsa will find her
answers and the key to defeating the
threat inside this ice cave there's a
good chance that she will learn she has
more abilities than just ice magic if
Elsa is getting more powerful every day
like the song says then she may have the
ability to control ice wind and fire
this would allow her to stop whatever
the threat to arendelle is she would
also be able to save the people from the
enchanted forest the forest for some
reason allowed her to clear the mist and
get through the forest obviously wants
Elsa to enter that's why she is being
called to there but who or what is
calling Elsa there are many theories
that her mom is alive and that her mom
had powers of her own the trolls
mentioned spirits in the forest it's
possible these spirits want Elsa to
enter the forest so that she isn't a
threat outside this is going to be the
biggest challenge Elsa has ever had to
overcome but she will be doing it alone
she has her sister and the rest of their
gang to help her they will help protect
her while Elsa learns how to defeat the
major threat to arendelle she will save
arendelle but she will probably nearly
lose herself while doing it but Anna
will be there to keep Elsa in check I
won't let anything happen to her what do
you think will happen in frozen - let us
know in the comment section thanks for
watching
for more great videos like this one
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you later
you